good morning monkey
we're making waffles you're making
waffles yeah i'm gonna be careful
good job dude
hey what's today
the weekend
yep
yep and like i said today is the weekend
we are going to be making some waffles
because he requested some waffles i know
it's peanut butter
mixer uh it is thank you it is pancake
mix
but
you can still make waffles so making
waffles we got this little waffle maker
at
um home goods maybe last year for
christmas and it's been
awesome it's been so perfect
because it's the perfect little size for
taika and just a nice little snack for
us you're gonna mix it oh my god i just
saw what happened you go faster because
because
you know how to do this
who me i could go fast yeah
good job okay so once we mix it then
what do we do
i'm gonna put chocolate chips in there
nope
i don't know
um we do the
we put it in the waffle maker
yep and then when it's done then what do
we do that needs to be like this yeah
you need to mix it up
let's get stuck in the mixer yeah no you
just got to keep mixing it don't mix
itself you just keep stirring it stir it
stir it stir it stir it
it looks like broiled food it looks like
what don't let go
it does
yeah okay
here you go tyka can you record me i
want to do it mama oh you want to do it
okay here
one second one second
yeah
okay i think this will work
yep put it on there
i think that looks good can i let go of
it
no no you no you hold it there you go
okay
i think you can close it now
can you let go
thank
you it yeah close it
no it's blue and then when it's not blue
or when the light turns off that means
it's
ready ready ready
hey google five minutes why
gosh oh okay yeah google you heard the
man
hey google 10 minutes yeah you heard the
man google do your job
go dude it's ready it's hot i know but
just open it real fast no just go fast
okay sure
oh the reveal
monkey dude okay so now let's take it
off
it's perfect now put some [ __ ] now you
put chocolate chips let's see what you
do
grand master chocolate chip guy what's
the cutest feet
listen though
oh it's melting down they're melting
it's melting already
yeah
they'll melt so fast yeah it's melting
super fast
yeah i decided to eat it
yeah
let me i'd never eat waffles well never
it's rare you should say
i did eat waffles but you could say it's
rare when i eat waffles
yes
wow masterpiece dude mustard pizza baby
hey you know what
hey what hey hey hey hello hey
looks great dude
i can't believe this you can't believe
why i've never ever never put the sugar
in the waffles before
well consider this your lucky day dude
okay i gotta put bacon on the
okay i messed up coming right back
okay so taika ate his first waffle
right now he's eating some bacon and i
made him
[Music]
why do you look like that look at all
that chocolate
he's watching his ipad
we ran out of eggs but this baking's
getting bad or old it's still good but
it was getting old that i just needed to
make it all right now i'm making
pancakes for papa and i have blueberry
strawberries i added some vanilla
extract and a little bit of sugar let's
see how they turn out i've never made
these so
flip them over so far
so good it looks pretty yummy to me
so i just took a bite why is it so blue
over here and these
are so bomb i haven't added anything on
them yet
and they are perfect
oh yes
okay
so i'm just gonna give a plate to papa
super dry because i'm telling you these
pancakes are already
super perfect sweetness
naturally sweet even though i added a
little bit of sugar
um
but yeah let's see what he says
okay papa try it never just try it
whoa
so
very good
that just looked crazy you don't cook
much but when you do it's very good i
hate you
i love you
so after
everything gets cooked and consumed my
favorite is having a clean
kitchen running uh
the dishwasher real quick i already
washed those by hand
now
look at that
[Music]
now i'm gonna bust the papa
watch some blade tiger you like blade
doesn't scare you no
what are you eating
let me see me hear you oh
my god he likes blade because he beats
up the vampires yeah but you know blade
is half vampire
wow
do you know he's a half vampire no i
love your mouth dude let me see let me
hear it
so cute dude
i love you in your pajamas let me see
let me see your pajamas dude
okay i'm being annoying i get it okay
fine i'll leave you alone i wonder where
papa bear's hand is
right here look
at
this
right here
it was here hey hey
excuse to touch me
i knew it you just want an excuse to
touch me
so here is today's look today we're
gonna do something super fun we're going
to an art museum
it's like
an earth art installation dealing with
everything on this planet um that's all
i really know about it it was honestly
a sponsored post on my instagram and
like it was playing a video and it just
looks so cool that i'm like we're doing
that today so that's what we're doing
today taika dressed himself i don't know
where he is psycho where are you
where
let me see
poke your head out
please
one
two
there he is
he's mad at us well he's mad at papa
because papa
tiger was giving him directions and papa
just does whatever papa wants
but
um taika has a game in mind and then dad
wants to do his own game so they're
doing their own games and then they get
frustrated at each other so right now
they're frustrated there he is
i always get surprised every time i see
this shirt right now we are next to
new york is that what's called new york
new york yep new york new york yeah so i
think this place or this museum this
earth
art exhibit
is on the strip um i believe
i don't know jack [ __ ] okay but i'm
guessing
it might be in a casino
i'm not sure
it's next to jean falls antonio
it sounds like you're saying my name
oh yeah
yeah so mgm right there
i don't know what that is oh i think
that's another cirque show that they
have
bart's favorite
roller coaster that's so scary do you
want to get on nah
plessy
no that one's too that guy i didn't know
there was a guy up there what's that all
about
yeah new york new york
remember when the lion used to be
really massive
and now it's that little puny thing of a
bobber you would have to walk in the
lion's mouth do you remember that
oh man i vaguely remember it yeah really
oh wow
yep now it looks like that
okay i got it
so
now we are on the strip look at this
we're right next to
but this is where we're trying to go to
arcadia you know it's funny it's called
arcadia you know what's funny even
funnier the paw patrol guy i heard him
through his mask hey come on let's take
a picture guys yeah who wants a tip
take a picture and give them a tip no
they took a picture all right okay who
wants to go
let's go let's go look it up in l.a
again i know
arcadia
so interesting okay let's go
okay so we are now inside about to head
down the first thing you need to do is
download an app to make it super
interactive and then the second is to
sign into their wi-fi but check this out
[Music]
there we go
hey cutie
[Music]
now we're going let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
and then one other person just helps you
out and holds that fingerprint down on
another ipad and then you'll see on the
left side there's
[Music]
is this all plastic bags
so these are
all plastic bags what a bummer dude
but when you begin to add up the noise
look at this
[Music]
are you gonna sit
much co2 down the atmosphere as the
global radiation
how cool the industry itself means
so this
is nets that are used to scrape to catch
a bunch of fishes
oh god and it's such a bummer because
after they use it they dump it in the
ocean floor these are actually been
repurposed
um and gathered
oh so sad but when they do the ocean
scraping they pick up a bunch of um fish
that aren't even meant to be
picked up did that suck
[Music]
as global warming causes the temperature
of the oceans to rise
vital planktons struggle to survive
since 1940s
whoa
super cool
[Music]
i like there's all this cool stuff and
then the bean bag is his favorite
[Music]
whoa
oh what was that
oh
next exhibit this one is land oh jesus
so we were just in the ocean oh no did
you get those ipads
[Music]
[Music]
so this is
[Music]
there are
[Music]
there's a lot of tigers
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that
it sees you
i can see it's looking at you
that's crazy
look come here come on come back out
come back out this way
let's see what it does okay ready go
[Music]
what is this doing what is this
is it a machine
a robot
[Music]
[Music]
let's act now
[Music]
[Music]
the bees it's about the bees
bees provide one of those horses
we need this out here
[Music]
[Music]
animals
come here look at there's a window look
in here
[Music]
creating your own compost
[Music]
whoa look at this comfortable dude
purify okay
oh my god
now this room is talking about purifying
naturally purifying your home and
they're highly recommending having a
bunch of house plants and just plants in
general because
um they have a lot of psychological um
and like mental
um
just other health benefits right like
obviously they're naturally purifying
the air
especially like in your house um
so
yeah that's what this one's about i'm
not too sure what this one is
[Music]
so we're in a vr room
climb on the road
whoa
gorilla
where's the big brother going
he's going that way he's going that way
he's going that way okay okay oh my
goodness
i'm going down
i'm going in
here
wait wait
scooby doo
oh my god
oh no scooby doo don't ruin the magic
put your mask back on dude put your
mouse back on
scooby doo
all right guys it's my favorite time of
the day which is time to stuff more food
in my mouth it is lunch time and we're
at this argentinian bodega place we've
been here before
um and it's really close to the strip
which is why when i yelled like oh what
should we eat this place popped up was
only a mile away and you guys know me i
freaking love steak especially
argentinian steak so now that i'm here i
gotta get the uh and tanya
so i'm gonna get that and i'm gonna show
you guys some of the stuff that they
have over in the grocery section
because i love seeing stuff that's like
native to the culture
so you can come here and you can get
chimichurri
we got prosciutto
all these sausages
which is like that breaded steak right
there
the world famous in kanye which is the
argentinian state
look at all these cuts oh man
oh short reds or as sup doc would say oh
my
do you god taiko will like fettuccine
alfredo i know this is our japan
restaurant
but he wants pasta argentinian food is
known for their uh pasta too you know
that cause they have a huge italian
influence
i don't know huge italian huge german
salad mike makes sense now yeah he's
half italian and he's
argentinian
yeah
hey mister you want cream sauce or
tomato sauce
[Music]
i love how pure
kids emotions and reactions are white
sauce is cream
oh you want the white sauce yes but the
white sauce is green
[Music]
this guy's hilarious because he says i
hate cream on my pasta like he's been
eating pasta his whole life in his
entire life his father ate pasta less
than seven times
do you know what i mean
he's like i hate cream on my pasta i'm
like you've only had pasta
less than ten times you're crazy
this guy's freaking nazos
it's definitely your jeans
yeah
everyone you guys could sell
[Music]
so papa
always takes a picture
of food but i never know why because he
never posts it anyway that's not half
dude that's not half either
you better be fair
are you thousands of food
huh
imagine this whole time i'm thinking
you're taking pictures of food
i go to your i go to your camera roll
and it's just your faces
it's just your face
you thought it was empanadas wow
that's a great photo
do you think your pup was funny
he's a silly guy huh
why are you sitting like a little boy
dude
can you be a baby again please dude no
okay fine that's fair um
[Music]
your hair looks so nice
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy is a natural comedian
let me see
let me do that again
i think he's laughing at the thought of
what he's doing
[Laughter]
because he starts cracking up before i
could even go go
okay monkey do you like your pasta
is that the pasta you wanted
this is cream dude
[Music]
you like cream
got them we got them got them got them
okay
look at this
let's feast
hey monkey yeah this is your first time
swimming since last year because
it was so cold are you excited to go
back swimming
wait what i'm gonna put
[Music]
you want to play a chill and then
somehow he's gonna magically be
completely submerged kids always get
scared when they reacquaint themselves
so it's always like that we'll see what
happens
yeah it's a big bounce house i think
someone's celebrating a birthday yeah
we have i'm gonna go play there well
you're not invited that's not your party
you can't just go to other people's
parties
here we are
in our community pool
such a beautiful pool and check out that
view over there
look what your son came to do he came to
water plants
it's in his jeans i said he could bring
any toy he wants for the water and i
thought he was gonna bring like a bow or
a ball
it's in our jeans that's cutie i hope he
starts a good landscaping company well i
mean it's in our jeans
my son is weird huh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
i can't believe you fell for that taika
this water is cold i don't know if this
water is cold or outside is way too hot
it's currently like 90 something degrees
out right now
so i don't know if it's because it's so
hot out here
that the water feels extra cold or it's
both or it's just
cold the water
no clue but
bottom line it feels [ __ ] cold
i haven't gone in the water yet
what's happening
all right so taika wants to race me okay
he's gonna are you gonna run or walk
whoa okay he's gonna run i'm gonna swim
i'm gonna see who gets to that side okay
go
you ready no you bomb accounts mama
counts
okay ready yep three
two one go
well
okay go backwards
[Music]
same
[Music]
taika always inspires us to take
pictures of him because he's just so
damn cute he's just living his regular
life and we're like we got to take a
picture of this inside he's always like
yeah tech is always like wait why we're
like just do what you did dude
out of the ones that i post there's pro
for everyone that i post there's
probably like 20 that i don't because
they're just so cute yeah our our camera
rolls are just flooded with type of
content
oh yeah wear your shirt you're gonna be
so cold later are you kidding me man
papa's the fun police huh
papa's never the phone police mom's a
fun police
yeah throw him in the pool
the pool's the jail
you go to jail get him get him get him
get him bad guy get him bad guy you go
to
i
jail
you guys play the weirdest games check
out the game they're playing it's his
idea i know boys have weird ideas man
what three water push-ups yeah okay let
me see
one
two
three wow
four
five
five
six
five how many do you think i could do
seven
seven that's a lot better go slow the
way he did
yeah
one
two
three
four
five
six
like ten
so you mean three
[Music]
[Music]
wow that's a lot
oh my god how long is this gonna go for
one twenty five
dude
i feel like this is gonna turn into a
gnarly game
someone's gonna end up banging their
face on the floor
okay let me see twelve then
oh oh
you're too close to the pool it's the
big is that on the side
that's four dude
five
go fast
[Music]
keep going
[Music]
so after the pool it is dinner time we
are at this place called district one
it's a vietnamese restaurant and they're
famous for
their uh obviously vietnamese food but
they're lobster fun so of course we have
to come here bring
mark's papa and we have joe and hannah
here
um so we're about to grub
have a good old time
and party with our mouths
i didn't sound right but you know what i
mean
maybe you don't
wow what is your dad saying he says
i come to america for this one
he doesn't have an accent like that he
has a vietnamese accent i don't know
where my son's stupid i eat
you didn't say anything like whoa this
is all mine
he has a poker flavor
i think he has to try it first and then
he'll let me know how it tastes
okay okay i'm gonna watch
the first bite we're watching the
national geographic
he put his glasses on and everything
this is the flavor it's very good whoa
that's crazy that's two for two papa
approved because my dad is everything's
like that's eye what was this what was
the first one
uh that's how we figured out oh
okay nobody knows that yeah
so dinner is concluded
so is this child
monkey
hey
i'm so sorry
oh he's okay yeah i'm a korean okay okay
well a mom's gotta do the mom's gotta do
thank you guys so much for watching and
i'll see you too